[Music]
netflix is in the news because ever
since netflix raised their fees i mean
really raised them
customers have been leaving in droves
customers are upset so yesterday netflix
ceo reed hastings released a video to
apologize for the rate hikes
customers still really mad the apology
didn't work that's why today
hastings released another video
with his latest plan to win you back
hello i'm reed hastings president and
ceo of netflix
our recent pricing changed from 9.99 a
month for combined streaming and dvd
services to 7.99 each per service i
admit was not our most popular move
but we want to win you back and that's
why you should consider our new free
service easy play where one of our
representatives will come to your house
personally open your netflix quickster
envelope then place the dvd in your dvd
player and get a playing do any dishes
you have in your sink
paint your house then if you want watch
the movie with you and answer any
questions you may have about it
second we're offering new cheaper plans
to choose from like the blindside plan
where for only 49 cents per month we'll
send you only copies of the sandra
bullock movie the blind side watch the
blind side send it back we'll send you
back another copy of the blindside
for only 1.49 per month we have the live
star plan where we will actually send
the star of any movie to your home
providing that movie stars jason biggs
or paul hogan
and returning dvds will be easier than
ever when you're finished simply throw
the dvd out of any moving car
place it in a bush tie it to a balloon
even flush it down the toilet
can't do that hand it to any elderly
person put it under your pillow throw it
in the ocean hide it in your local
grocery store's produce section or leave
it on a public bus don't worry we'll get
it
but listen we messed up and we're sorry
not sorry enough to lower the price but
still pretty sorry
come back please
[Applause]